all right
all right lottie bloody where'd you grow
up where you from
originally from los angeles california
south central south central and tell me
about your childhood you had both your
parents
as a kid yeah got mama and dad
good childhood excellent perfect
really that's nice to hear
and uh what kind of kid were you in high
school
a sneaky hit i always wanted to get into
everything
i wanted to get by i passed everything
without nobody knowing
never liked the homework never liked the
teachers
i don't like them telling me nothing
most of the time i really didn't like
waking up in the morning even going to
school i like to go to school in the
daytime
like i didn't really too much even like
school did you finish high school
maybe halfway
so today you're you're working as a
prostitute
yeah you could say that and uh
what age did you start doing that
um
i say about like 15 15. i was like maybe
15
15 14 somewhere near yeah
it's it's a common story and
did you how did you how did you be how
did you get started did you did you know
somebody that was doing it did you have
friends did you
no i would always see people around the
neighborhood or
my friends or my friend's friends or my
sister friends
maybe people i've seen at school or
i always seen the videos or i seen the
fly girls with the jury
the money the car you know like i want
to always wanted things like that on my
own
like without asking mom and dad so i
knew it was only one way to get it
though was to have a job but then i'm
like
[ __ ] a job like it's what's in the
streets like i want to know what the
ghetto girl's doing in the streets and i
stepped off the porch and started
hanging outside and
meeting friends that new friends that
have friends and
you know i got around do you recall your
first time
first the first guy that picked you up
um
no i was at a club and i met somebody
and um i was getting into one of my
friends to be the tech and i wanted to
leave the club early
and they didn't want to take me so i was
like i'll give you a ride home like yeah
and i was so mad so i was like [ __ ]
let's go
and he gave me a ride home and
on the way home he was uh talking to me
or whatever telling me i was cute and
etc etc and i was i wasn't really like
buying it like i wasn't paying no
attention like i wasn't really like
acknowledging what he was saying i was
just i was faded and i was mad at the
fact
of everything was involved like
and he was all like um
you don't want to go home yeah you want
to go chill i'm like
like my time is money and like you know
i was young i was hot like you know
i was a hot girl back then well
then it's still probably now you know
right you know
but um
i say in my younger days like
i was i was the [ __ ] you know so i was
always like
my time is money and if i got to see her
and talk to you got to pay me for
for everything like you know the times
ticking like you know
and he was like um what you mean by that
i'm like well
the longer i send the card to you the
more money you have to pay me he's like
oh i got to give you money i'm like yeah
you want to spend time with me on the
show
he's like all right let's go to the room
and he's like um
i'll give you 200 bucks he's like to go
chill me out the room like go chill with
you at the wrong for just 200 bucks i'm
like how long we're going to be there
he was like um we could chill for a few
hours but he's like i'll get the room
for the rest of the night into the
morning
i'm just thinking to myself like [ __ ]
my mama not going to be tripping she
know after the club
i normally go to my home girl's house or
i come in
i go home it's like [ __ ] that i'm chill
out to the morning [ __ ] it everybody
gonna be looking for me i'm gonna come
back with money
that's all i was thinking about just the
money so
i went to the room with a [ __ ]
we actually chilled like you know i got
high i was being sneaky see then i was
sniffing coke
you know i was doing drugs oh my god i
was just
i was terrible at 15 at 15 yeah
i was living on 11th and broadway um you
know it was getting hot we got faded and
whatever whatnot the morning came he
broke me off
you know and you know that was pretty
much
after that
but now i didn't you know experience
more
seeing more no more so you know
every dollar counts what have you
learned in your years of doing this
how dangerous it is i mean yeah it could
be dangerous because i'd have been
through some [ __ ]
like i'd have been i didn't got in cars
with certain people and
they trying to fight me stab me all type
of [ __ ] because of
someone going their way and just stuff
got out of hand
yeah you can you can get you can die out
there actually
yeah you've been arrested oh yeah
i got arrested
my friend she won well i was walking
down the street one day from my house
which is on her left in broadway i was
walking down the street to my homey
t-way house
and it was this little [ __ ] that he had
and she wanted the
she wanted to learn how to date tricks
and [ __ ] but he was going he wanted to
put the [ __ ] down on fed
in on the third so i'm like i'm like
i'll take her like i'll sure what's up
he was like
show that [ __ ] buddy i'm like for sure
so many [ __ ] we gonna fig
we out there i'm telling her like pay
attention to certain cars like
you know you didn't car with some
persons or he won't touch you or
he's like too shaved off or too bald or
you know in the face or something like
don't talk to him like if they don't
touch you first don't talk to him
but this time i got in the car with her
the guy wanted to date her in the car
i'm like well you guys stay in the back
i'll drive
mind you i'm only 15. they may give me
the keys to this car
i'm driving down the runway
[Music]
the police pull us over i'm thinking the
guy was
vice he wouldn't even advice it was it
was really a you know
a customer and they stopped us and when
they put us out the car she was naked he
was naked
they had the helicopters on us oh my god
it was like the most embarrassing day
ever because when they stopped us they
stopped us in front of some black people
house the [ __ ] came outside
and it was all looking like i got this
little young girl with y'all
and cause i was i was a young cat you
know
they was looking at me like she doing
driving a car with a girl a [ __ ]
you know so they took me to jail
you know my my brother he came down and
talked to me because my brother he said
he's a shirt as well
so i went to an innate police station i
was so embarrassed because they were
sending me like
who are your family and how come contact
them because like we can't take you to
jail because you're under age
and that is that and i was i was all
being big mother like
i ain't got no family and what do you
say they finally got me to tell them my
name when i tell them my name
is like we got somebody i want to talk
to you like i was thinking about it at
the time but i wasn't really thinking
i go put me in this little office hit me
in this chair they take the cuffs off me
they only handcuffed me once
what to the chair what i was like it's
like sit right here somebody gonna come
talk to you
so i'm sitting there sitting there time
go by my brother walked in there and he
was like lucas
i couldn't even look at him i let the
whole time i was there i never gave him
eye contact we never contacted eyes the
whole
time like once i seen him walk in and i
knew it was him like my brother anthony
like literally my brother like i grew up
from
like you know oh my god i was like
i swear to god it was like shocking like
it was it was stupid it was something
like a person can never just like
experience or see like you know it was a
not a shocking or surprising it was like
like irrational like you know you're
you're ashamed of your
situation i was i was embarrassed i felt
humiliated i felt like
like you know like oh my gosh and then i
felt as bad as on his behalf too because
you know he works there
and he was just he was talking to me
it's embarrassing for him and for you
yeah it is his little sister at that his
baby sister out there
you know running it up just you know
he was talking to me like i i couldn't
even i can't even tell you right now
what he was saying to me because he was
saying something to me and i was just
everything was just
bleeding in my head i'm just thinking
sort of like oh i am [ __ ] up now for
real
so you've worked with pimps before
yeah are you currently working with the
pet
i mean
i mean you can say it no yeah
no okay we don't need to you don't need
to answer
in in the past when you've worked with
pims let's let's word it that way
how were those how were those
relationships oh see i was always the
you know i was young then so i was
always the the first one you know
like all the [ __ ] to get mad because
he'll treat me some type of different
way like i didn't have to be that
that [ __ ] that i had to get put down
every day or nothing like you know i got
the
you know get my weight when you know i
was like a madam young though you know
yeah special treatment oh my god it was
lovely
like i don't know i i got the
the book smartness to the street
smartness i put it together
like you know it's like so my game was
kind of too tight for it
like i started off really kind of young
at that [ __ ] so
as time grew and i grew that like you
know
i got to book smart for that [ __ ] tell
me about the uh
the relationship with the pimp i mean so
many of my viewers are just
mystified as to why a female would
i mean because it's protection it's
protection right i mean
he's gonna come he's gonna he's gonna do
whatever he needs to do
to to at the end of the day satisfy
the [ __ ] as well and make sure that
she's safe she's
she got that comfort like you know he's
there he's like he's saving her like you
know what i'm saying
and she gives she get what she wants
from her time like
so you're giving him all your money
yeah every every yeah but it's this i
mean that's the
that's the beauty of it that's that's
the whole concept of
being a prostitute you know
you're like you're like um ongoing
you're ongoing [ __ ] that just can't
help yourself but the
to [ __ ] get money there is there's no
other way you can put it that's just
straight blank like peer point
just you know you get out there get the
money and pay him but it's not a
situation that you are opposed to
it's something that kind of works for a
girl right i mean yeah
sometimes you got to use what you got to
get what you want why not
you don't have to necessarily always
[ __ ] [ __ ] neither to get what
you want
you know like me i got a mouthpiece like
you know i'm not saying like sucking
dickwise like but
you know like you know you have to have
some type of ism as well
not just only his ism you know but you
got to have you know
you got that something being a processor
you have to really be dedicated to it
you know
that's something you have to really want
like you can't just be a loose [ __ ] out
there running just like
oh i got a pimple because he's down to
beat your ass
like you don't pay him his money you
don't come in right you don't go back
you're gonna be beat the [ __ ] up
he gonna you know he can does that
because he's your daddy
you know what i'm saying like it's
something you sign up for it's like
sometimes it's it's no way out of that
[ __ ] because he
he that's all he knows that's all he
that's how he survives that's how he eat
that's how
you know it's a lot to it though
is it easy for a girl to get out if she
wants to get out of that relationship
oh yeah she's gonna pay whatever he
wants so you have to pay to get out hell
yeah
hell yeah or you wouldn't be able to
to sell not liquor coochie nowhere
so how much do you uh do you making a
night of doing this
how much do you bring in and give to
your pen
see i mean i'm i don't know
i'm different from a lot of girls like
guys when they see me
they always be like you're cute you got
titties and
i like your smile and you got white
pretty teeth
and yeah you look like that type of girl
so you know
i get paid i get tipped i get extra
overpaid
you know i i ain't no joke i don't play
once time
tick like once i'm on on the clock it's
a time stop
oh yeah there's no games every i mean
every second every
every minute i don't play no [ __ ]
games
and are some even for interviews like
when the guy pull up and it
and i probably know what he wants or
whatever you know
you know like for my time like what's up
don't want me fed you you want money
just talk to him in the car well
i know spanish as well too so it goes
both ways for me
and are some interactions more
not so much sex for money but sometimes
you're figuring out how to
get the guys watch your jewelry or
wallet oh you see
oh yeah cause he look it
some guys that pull up they want to date
you you get there
date them and they'd be like oh i have
to go to the bank for my money and then
they try to pull a fast one
your first instance is gonna be
take his for everything in his pockets
take his wallet his keys
everything strip him [ __ ] naked now
see now it's announced
it's a ball game because now it's like
my way or nowhere to highway and
at the end of the day it's going to be
highway for me to get the [ __ ] up out of
there and he's going to be
an [ __ ] nick without nothing until my
daddy gets there or whatever whatever
9 out of 10 i'ma try to solve the issue
before he get there because i know how
ugly to get
you know so i'm gonna do what i have to
do leave him leave him
stranded and take off with everything
that's just the way the game works yeah
but in the process of all day
it gets kind of dirty a lot of things
can happen something will happen
it's a situation it's a problem
that's where the park come in where you
can get yourself killed and hurt because
some of the [ __ ] they fight
back
they fight back and then you know they
put up for they
you know they put a little fight up for
their [ __ ] but it'd be like you know
you're wrong so that's what it is
that's why certain girls get raped now
because some guys get paid before they
get
their job done or they blow jobs or
their sex or whatever what not
like they'll just break off the [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] will run off
you know so i don't blame certain
certain
tricks that do day [ __ ] and that
happened like i don't blame them for
that like
you know what makes it hard for a person
like me like you know
pay up and get what you want you know
some [ __ ] they don't do that now they
were like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i want you to do me first [ __ ] and then
i'm gonna pay you you know so be iffy
like
those ones like that i'd be like
what kind of guys do you pick up or what
kind of guys pick you up
i don't know how i attract all the
ballers for some reason i'm not
bullshitting you i
i don't try to say i'm all that but i'll
attract all
the the the right ones and it'd be like
like you know i can see that they'd be
like they'd be trying to be so petty
with me when i be saying a whole
like but i believe you know
i get my share i make sure i get my
portion believe that
but you know the good is for the good
and the baddest it's very bad
and are drugs part of the picture for
you the drugs
oh yeah i was a cocaine terribly
i swear i i used to have so many cold
nights and days like
i can never not remember like a drug is
a [ __ ] it's a hellified thing to
do
once you start doing a drug and you're
already in the streets
it's all it's a [ __ ] pillow to swallow
telling it's like it's hard it's hard to
grab back because it's like you get so
deep into it
and you've been to the streets into the
game life the money
just just the whole the emperor just
everything like you know if he and don't
don't be living
at a goodwill's home you know like
where the roof over your head like where
you can sleep every night you got hot
water you got
you know you got gas electricity you
know what i'm saying got clothes
you don't have to worry about for the
[ __ ] get tampons every month and
all that don't don't [ __ ] that over tell
me because it's
hard to get that [ __ ] back it's hard
very hard and it's not easy to get out
of it like it's easy to jump in
but to get that [ __ ] right back tight
it'll never be the same
that's why a lot of the girls don't save
money right
the drug drug happen gets out of control
oh yeah
see then that's where the pimp posts to
step in some of them don't give a [ __ ]
some of them let the [ __ ] burn
themselves out and go to the next [ __ ]
that's why pimps got one two three four
five they got plenty
what one won't do the next one will
believe that
does this this lifestyle get you down
sometimes
you say what you get depressed sometimes
just from doing this
hell yeah cause it's like
i miss miss me going and coming
and saying like i haven't been
i don't know how many places without my
parents about maybe even being underage
and everything like i hadn't seen a lot
i hadn't been
from here and there like i'd have been
to to lexico i've been in mexico i
hadn't been to tijuana
i'd have been in new orleans and it's
hard to believe i hadn't been to vegas i
haven't been to texas i haven't been
uh who was that we went to florida
no i didn't go to florida
where did we go oh we went to miami
that's florida
oh it's florida okay there you go my bad
you told me that earlier
yeah um where else did we go
oh we went on a trip to the bahamas with
my friend mom one time too as well i was
young
[ __ ] oh my god it was one summer
vacation oh
we have fun this is a pimp who organizes
these trips
oh yeah cause look it believe it or not
i had this
i had this i had this friend named todd
and he had come visit me i was like
17 16. and my mama found out so
i stopped [ __ ] with the [ __ ] but he
was on me so hard like where he had just
come and just dropped me off bills just
because like
just i'm like i can't talk to you like
my mom know and
like you know this is it's gonna get
ugly for you he start paying me to
to talk to my friends like my friends
moms and all that oh my like every other
week they can come drop me off two three
five hundred bills
just go get him a girl make sure she's
right he gonna
break me off before anything and when i
come back breaking me off
oh my ace to be crazy he'll come find me
wherever i'm at come
find me far wherever it doesn't matter
like
the game gets deep
does your family know you do this
i mean for the ones that really know me
what are the personality traits that you
have that help you do this
you're very confident yeah
i'm good in anything
i try to i try not to be perfect
sometimes but i intentionally
just don't just slam it on it just
you know like i feel like you'd be good
at whatever you put your mind to
yeah i am it's just interesting that you
put your mind to this
right what do you think led you down
this path
a lack of stress just i'm coming to that
point
like where i feel like i'm going down
this little brick road like you know
and it's like once you get to that brick
road there's nowhere to turn to nowhere
to go nowhere to
for nothing so it's like before you get
that far it's like
stop think about it
i do i want to continue on living like
this like when i don't have to at that
i can have it all made out but i choose
to go my route i choose to go my way i
choose to get money how i get money
like you know
i survive on my own i don't even have a
job
anything i don't even get gr
nothing nothing else i guess no type of
income
at all period point blank and you don't
pay any taxes
who to pay him to myself my [ __ ]
my parents what
what was the best time of your life
the best time of my life really that's
embarrassing
the best time in my life i was at the
beach
and
i was in to lexico across the border
this guy named alex martinez he
sent for me in a uber i was at my friend
at least house
and i was getting into it everybody was
having a bad week and he said from he
said
go to western union give them these
numbers make sure i have your id
and once you get that call me i go to
west senior and get my id
they get me back three thousand dollars
i call them like what's this money for
he like um
your lift will be outside in front of
the leash i was like in 30 minutes to
just be ready say just come like that
between
with you and what i sent you with i'm
like
okay so i'm sitting there
waiting waiting live come and i was in
i'm like um where am i going to there's
like oh you know
um a three to four hour drive like i'm
about to take you all the way across the
border to mexico i'm like
what the [ __ ] like and remind you i'm
already on the freeway
like like where am i going like you know
i was i was noticing i was on the
freeway for a long time i'd have seen
the
the graveyard and seeing cows and all
type of [ __ ] i'm like where the [ __ ]
i'm going like where is he sending me
and i go out there and he
buy me he bought me my own car i had a
mitsubishi
um she took me on the beach
took me on a bull ride like
see then when when i went out there i
picked up on another drug
i stopped doing coke i started doing
meth
i was on the beach i was smoking i was
just like living like living like a
queen
like you know like i don't know
i went out there and i didn't come back
for almost
maybe from that one time you seen for me
i never came back to california for
maybe like six seven eight months
my mom thought somebody had kidnapped me
or something i got
like because i didn't call nobody i
didn't say nothing i was i was really
just too wrapped up in it and just out
there for just the good like
just started from nothing and just live
my life up like from there
like literally didn't call anyone um how
i got in contact with my family
was that um man was taking pictures and
somebody calmed down the picture and was
like
till i didn't contact her mom it's an
emergency like 9-1-1
when they when they said that and i
realized it reminds you i was already
out there for maybe about
a good three months i'm like [ __ ] like
let me go home like
i'm just just just just ran on and just
forgot about my whole career my life i
had behind me like
and i'm like i'm in mexico like i'm i'm
here with my friend and it was like come
home
and i'm like like come home
what like i never i didn't know i was
already 18
i was grown so i'm like come home like
i like it out here what you mean come on
i'm gonna stay here
i stayed out there i started getting
into [ __ ] i got a job
and oh lord from there i got a house
and i started selling drugs and then we
got home for ransom
all type of [ __ ] happened like i was
[ __ ] wrong with the cartels that show
just i don't know
it got ugly then i came back and then i
was going back and forth and now i'm
here
like i didn't from for me adventuring
just a little bit
it expanded like a lot
have you been in love before huh have
you been in love before
have i been in love i was loved two
times in my life
no
i was loved two times in my whole life
with a guy named danielle kyle
and a boy named demonte morgan
that's it i loves no one
i love myself
does does doing this for for a living
get in the way of your romantic
relationships make them more difficult
no because if i had a [ __ ] well if i
had a boyfriend right now
well for for guys that really know me
and
we've been in certain real relationships
or we've been in a little whatever
i don't know we've been on dates or been
knowing each other like
[ __ ] know how i like myself [ __ ]
know how i like to be treated [ __ ]
know how
my attitude is [ __ ] know how my mood
swings are they know how to
deal with me approach me have me around
certain people you know
they just know how to do me like you
know so
it is it's really not too many
you know like guys out there that like
i let even look at me like that or look
at me they look at me more as like a
homegirl or sister typewise because
like i'm a girly at the end of the day
but majority of the time i'm like
you know i'm not i'm like that got a
good girl you know
you know i got like a lot of
personalities you know so it's like
you can run me this way i'll be this way
one day you can run me that way and i'll
be that way
do you think living this lifestyle has
changed
maybe it could be yeah
yeah because it turns it turns me all
all the ways that i know i shouldn't be
turning and it's it's
at the end of the day when i look back
it's nothing for me to
be ashamed wait
yeah no because i'm grown so it's like
who gives a [ __ ] like you know i love my
mom i love my dad
there's no disrespect like you know they
raised me to be
a young lady you know and be the woman i
am but
i just choose the
go my routes and go my ways you know
i mean on my freeway there's no traffic
if you don't get in the wrong blame
you think you're addicted to the
lifestyle the fast money and the
yep lack of responsibility yeah and the
danger
yeah it'd be very hard to quit right
i'll never quit i'll never give up mama
told me whatever i do be best at it
be the better be the better out of it
make sure i'll do it whatever it is
she didn't raise no quitter now that
what she didn't do
are you able to stand outside of
yourself and look at what you're doing
and
see how yeah all the time when i when
when i want to be
just when i want to be later i'll give
me a room
be myself give me what i want give me my
app whatever whatever and i'll go in
there
and just chill and i just look at myself
like you know i can be this person one
day i can be that person the next day
i choose to be the way i am because
maybe because i have a baby
you have a child i have no kids i'm a
woman
of my own i'm a baby of both sides mom
and dad
and they have i'm the baby both sides so
it's it's you know it's it's left up to
me sometime at the end of the day but it
no it's not because my sisters and
brothers they having a lot of little you
know
they got a lot of them so i don't need
that out of me
real [ __ ] would you describe yourself as
happy
no
i'm humbled
what do you think drove you down this
path in life
it's unusual especially coming from a
good childhood
it's an unusual choice right
being outside
being outside seeing things that i
wanted
that i knew mom and dad wouldn't get
so you grew up close to the streets and
you saw girls doing this and it just
kind of became
tempting i mean i'm not really cuz then
that means i was a follower
i just seen certain stuff that i wanted
and
i was always that type of girl but i
want it i for sure got that [ __ ] believe
that like
any i mean whatever whatever my mind
always i seen or if i lay my eye on it
or whatever whatever trust
me nines out of ten i promise you i i
touched it and got it
it might have been all the way mines but
i i got it and put it in my position to
you know to whatever whatever it is
i don't think my mind seen her or
thought or
or had any actions or anything that i
have not touched yet thousands of
dollars almost
probably a few meal tickets [ __ ] i
didn't rent the money
cars house everything
i didn't had it all and lost it
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years of doing this
you can't take nothing back
once i mean once it's gone it's gone
you start something you better be bound
to finish it
if you're on a good path it's not like a
pass you're gonna [ __ ] the path
uh me personally i think if you want to
[ __ ] the paths don't [ __ ] the path don't
don't try to go straight and then [ __ ]
up and then go straight
it don't go if you're gonna [ __ ] up [ __ ]
up all the way if you're gonna go
straight
straight go straight all the way you
know cause when you when you
when you do good and then you [ __ ] up
and then you try to do good
it makes you have problems in life and
then when you be bad and then be good
and be bad
you have problems in life it follows you
a thousand miles
and it makes it hard for you to try to
even become yourself or try to
be that person that you you know you
need to be
or you want somebody to know and respect
you as
you know what i'm saying like you can't
grow up
being a thief and then when you get
older not expect no one to be like oh
yeah i know her
like she was a perfect person all but
[ __ ] to see him like oh y'all knew
her she was a thief back then like you
know [ __ ] like that
or y'all know her she was smart all her
[ __ ] life like she you know
she won't you can't put numb past her
like she's a one
somewhere down that line that [ __ ]
follows [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so it's like
you're gonna be good be good you're
gonna be bad do your [ __ ]
just know every action has a reaction
it is karma like a [ __ ] i
believe in it
because i'll be out there certain days
and it'd be
you know dog is like every dog got his
day like you know
it's been some days i just didn't want
to give up and it don't need to be no
reason about it like
but it's because i put up the fight
forever it's just
everything i got i have to make sure
everything everything
i can't be out there without no money
because i was raised
i never went without you know i never
was the kid that that needed something i
always had
everything i wanted right there
now it's like i'm i'm i don't even have
to be out there on my own but now that
i'm out there on my own
and and i want to live the life and all
this i have to make sure i have this
this that everything costs
every time you step out the door it
costs you can't go outside which just
a dollar oh no you're not i don't think
you'll survive
that's out every time you go out the
house you gotta have
money
all right lottie thank you so much for
the interesting talk
thank you you're fascinated thank you
very much
you